le dernier film Marvel que j'ai vu était les
vengeances et soyons honnêtes, c'était
incroyable,
vous savez que tous les fans de bandes dessinées
rêvaient de voir tous ces personnages sur
grand écran 1,5 milliard de dollars dans le monde
et c'est combien d'argent Avengers moi
c'est l'un des  les films les plus réussis
de tous les temps les
gens aiment la fantasy d'évasion Marvel est
un mythe moderne d'aujourd'hui quand je
grandissais j'étais le seul gars sur
probablement 500 miles qui pouvait vous dire
que Tony Stark était Iron Man non nous
savons tous que c'est génial
[Musique  ]
c'est récemment, il y a deux ou trois ans,
nous vivions aussi dans la peur que oh mon
dieu,
un mauvais film de super-héros allait se produire
et que toute l'industrie hollywoodienne
allait abandonner et ne plus le faire,
ce n'est plus le cas maintenant en voyant tous ces
films c'est en quelque sorte  comme une validation
pour les bandes dessinées parce que c'est le
super-héros qui est maintenant arrivé dans les films et
ils le font très bien,
nous avons construit suffisamment de choses, ce qui signifie que le
marbre a accumulé suffisamment de
moment de pâtes  euh où je ne sais pas ce qui va
les arrêter
le super Anejo Anita Romeo rencontré donc
Hollywood le pop culture est dans un passif
Antonio de Seneca formidable n'est qu'une
Fiat importable terriblement spéculative l'
auto mile de Wall Street dans la société
Marvel Entertainment mezzo mezz
spider-man Iron Man Wonka Captain
America alpha D clarifie l'ensemble piloté cette
fusée inquiétante Robin dit à propos de ce
Romaric yozma donc V Humira net du
système que
vous